[Music]
if you close your eyes you might think
you're in the upside down
in a minute i'ma need a sentimental man
a woman to pump me up it's a little less
upbeat on the tonight show as stranger
things villain jamie campbell bower
pulls out his scary vector voice to
cover lizzo's hit song
in a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't know whether to be impressed or
terrified with jaime's skills either way
his delivery of vechna is pretty solid
no matter what he's reciting
this is a daily affirmation for wekner
okay
i am strong
i am beautiful
i
am
the actors definitely made his mark on
and off screen as stranger thing's
scariest character ever
i want you
to
and last month jamie told et how he's
handling the overwhelming fan response
i giggle often i mean my reaction tends
to be what what i just gave you it's
funny i'm british so i'm often terrible
at even you know receiving praise at all
um but it takes a village right and um
and and to be
to be a small part of bringing something
like this to life again is a privilege
and it's an honor i'm just kind of like
thank god it worked
thank god it worked and if you thought
vecna got his vengeance in season four
try and stay very still
[Music]
it will all be over soon
jamie teased there's likely more vechna
in store for season five
if you thought it had reached the limit
of what was possible for this show
there's more to go there's more to come
yeah it gets bigger and scarier and
wilder
i know you're in there wake up
wake up
until then we're just happy to hear
jamie or vegna giving us less nightmares
and more lizzo
in a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you